ich habe einfach mein ziehvater geboxt
alter das protour und er kann man nicht
siehst mich hinterher schwimmen oder
tötet mich ich komme mir wissen stellt
du bist so auffällig hey leute und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde hide
and seek verstecken in minecraft endlich
mal wieder mit face käm ich habe nicht
gesagt dass die face camp firma weg sein
wird sondern dass die eventuell manchmal
wiederkommen wird also zusammen mit
einem personen realo hast knapp gewinnt
nur töten wir spielen so anhalten
ich bin vom server geflogen es sei
möglich dass ist das macht auf jeden
fall spaß vor da würde ich sagen geht
mir daraufhin siemens als auch in
anderen liedern hatte wurden erstmals
wieder in 720 eingehen das geht ein
bisschen zuschauer besuchten geben im
fall eines anderen mannes heraus eine
wirtschaftsschule super hier läuft
einfach mal was wo ist jedes freies in
freiheit leben dies legen hier 58
bringen 58 okay ich bin drin also
herzlich willkommen zu halten sieht ihr
leben auch schon die ganzen coolen neuen
blöcken 1.6 hinzugefügt wurden welche
lag habe nicht richtig schnieke auf
jeden fall dürfte tochter heftig ja
keiner wissen zweiten sieg ist einer ist
nachher der typ der suchen muss und die
anderen müssen sind blöcke und ich bin
ein bücherregal glaube ich ist mio ich
bin ich suche ich bin dann verkackt
haben
der block unten rechts der block der
minister genau genau muss ich mich wo
hinstellen oder muss ich rechnen ein und
geht 1
du musst dich irgendwo hinstellen muss
einfach nur hinstellen war es zeit
abläuft
ich gehe das nie so versteckt was
einfach keiner findet ich will so hier
schon bücherregal aber ich glaube der
finde mich hier bei diesen teams gibt es
gibt es gibt dennoch darüber wenn du
dich in ein bücherregal und so hat noch
ein stellt sicher dass auch klar
normalerweise nicht gefunden okay ich
bin jetzt ein wiesel ist mein
bücherregal auf einmal verzaubert das
heißt dass solide geworden bist du weißt
dass du etwas so aus er wird zum app
gehören okay gut weil ich bin jetzt im
bücherregal und ich stehe hier einfach
irgendwo in der ecke neben zu anderen
bücherregalen und der suche hatte 262 l
282 sekunden zeit um uns zu suchen
richtig richtig und wir sind es 22 leute
die sich versteckt haben und zwei leute
suchen uns das heißt ich bin bücherregal
stehen oder ecke wenn der typ ich
gefordert muss der recht kräftig drauf
machen richtig der haut ich mir
holzschwerter der haube
wer bist du eigentlich was bricht bin
ich bin ein verkappter kurt block ich
bin ein amboss und sitze im wasser und
so will es das man höre schon das unter
meiner ist er das erste mit seinem klub
gewusst und haut dann auch darum
irgendwie gleich fix auch in holzweiler
können eigentlich jolo machen direkt ob
die auf die suche draufgehen die
versuchen zusammenzuklappen wir können
auf die supra die kann die suche töten
als blöcke navigeräte holzschwert
leichen das haben auch gemeint ist
einfach auf die draufgegangen sind in
der familie getötet
die hiesigen schweine japan gewann nein
aber das macht mehr spaß als wir uns
schützen
als nächstes ein spielmodus bekommen
normalerweise ist diese versteckst dich
gfk irgendwas ich packen die einen
runterholen oder so und da kommst du
wieder dass die punkte
oder halt nicht ein bisschen grund
wurden in rio weg wie auch einfach noch
einen anderen lok auf mehr verschwinde
zum aufnehmen einfach komplett
langweilig irgendwie ihr sei der mann
ist einfach so wie den und schreit die
ganze drum dann ist natürlich was
anderes machen alles irgendwie total der
tragisch und auf jeden fall auf jeden
fall wenn man so ein bisschen was ist
denn jetzt wenn ich mit dem holzschwert
jetzt auch die darauf die töte das
funktioniert auf jeden fall dann kannst
du entweder die chance selber suche zu
werden wenn du hier wie dieser crazy
buch ab 990 goethes wirst oder die spawn
neuer kann sich dann wieder verstecken
aber das miese ist gerade vor mir steht
einfach einander block und lockt ich
seit ich komme es beim verpacken
versteck nicht hey wie mach nicht raus
für mich hat sich etwas andere holzblock
zu und heftiger geklemmt und jetzt
bekomme ich nicht raus ich bin in so
einem ist wie in so einem wasser
aufgefangen quasi abgefragt du kannst
jetzt warum ich häng ich ihn fest ich
will aber nicht auf
wenn ich mehr gewinnen blutdruck ist
komme ich verrate jetzt einfach baff ich
hätte mich vielleicht nicht um ändern
soll einfach scheiße läuft auf mich zu
[ __ ] [ __ ] tadic ac a d
ich meine ich weggelaufen achtung ich
bin selber suche jetzt selber sucht
jetzt das macht spaß sich aber gefangen
ich komme ich raus weil ich bin ich bin
frei ich bin frei kate ja cool
ok guten tipp muss ich selber andere
suchen versuchen über zu finden bin so
ein hässlicher ist ein richtig hässlich
aber ich liebe es wäre zu einfach indem
ich weiß ist das eine ist das kenne ich
auch machen welche zwar voll da sie aber
egal wo du bist vielleicht geht's
einfach auf die drauf was ist eine kiste
ist kisten weil sie gar nichts kommt um
auf die auf die web an es gibt hier das
hälfte so richtig eröffnen
neinstedt kannst in die kiste wein glas
blog das verschweißen das fähigkeit das
war richtig heftig meint oskar lapp luca
was geht ab was geht ab nein man kann
auch einfach an einfach jeden block zu
schlagen oder gibt kann ich mir
normalerweise kamen da immer so ein
gerücht doch schlagbar immer weiter den
boden bekommt so richtig klappt es
geräusch besseres als richtig klappt es
soll die leute daran hindern
aber ich mein ohr oder mehr verloren zu
und quatschen tipps von michael j
meine pace vor käding rät lorenz komisch
ein tokens punkte kann man super ist es
das spiel echt geil er als als
verstecken es ist halt immer schwierig
es gibt halt ärgerlich aber es gibt
verschiedene märz auch noch zu hause
manchmal recht schwer aber das ist wenn
man sich bis zum ende verstecken kann
dann hat man gewonnen
dittmann mega vier punkte führen ist der
könig kann sich ja ich finde es nicht
leicht ist es cool wenn man das mal
wirklich nur in der privaten glaube ich
spielen könnte weiß das wäre so wie wenn
du es machen können das wäre perfekt
die ganze zeit die leute man kann nicht
jeder blog seite man kann doch einfach
sein oder irgend sowas ungenau und zaun
gibt glaube ich holzblock amboss es gibt
es noch ich meine das war's schon
cobblestone glaube ich nicht dass wir zu
krass aber echt krass richtig miese im
wasser ihren fall viele blogs herr
blöcke erstmal gucken ja das schwimmen
schon übels viele durch durchs wasser
ich sehe auch keine hat die auswahl
zwischen dezember und deswegen mussten
wir wollen das auf jeden fall pvp action
ganz ja dass ich glaube da werden wir
gleich einfach immer noch unter
aufnehmen zeit bleibt weil sonst nach
dieser runde mache ich einfach dann hat
hier in diesem spiel war noch nicht an
menschen den neuen park packen müsste
dir dann einfach schreiben ob ihr noch
mehr unterhalten stick haben wollte weil
ich meine das ist eigentlich anständig
wenn man sich versteckt dann kann man
sogar etwas quatschen das sogar abend
vorbei nicola mit gewonnen die
heidelsheimer remane beides geht man
wird um 150 punkte er kommen hierbei
diesem bei dieser nase hier bei den
willicher kannst du später noch sachen
kaufen also kanzler den kompost 3000 ja
wenn du darauf geht's hier 3.000 compact
3000 komfort 2001 melodie zusammen
gespielt hast kannst du dann die falsche
neue blöcke kaufen um dich halt besser
zu verstecken oder so ein scheiß
das hat auch ganz schön dich ja und das
ist quasi halten
dass man nochmal hier direkt wieder 850
und die extrem square ist haben wir
schon spieler das team ist
doch ich bin ein holzblock ein holzstamm
kann mich dann als guten plan vorstellen
kann ich mich auch in waldeck gesetzen
oder so das geht leider nicht es war
richtig fährt das geht nicht
ich hätte eigentlich direkt von anfang
an seagate zu sein irgendwie hat mich
also einfach in dieses loch einstellen
und ein herunterfallen
man könnte auch sich jetzt zu gucken wo
die ganzen anderen werke so hingehen
was bist du denn bis zum haus drinnen
wurden player überhaupt kein plan wohin
kann
bist du bei so einem haus mit was sind
das denn für vollidioten das sind super
cop ist und sie setzt nicht einfach auf
die treppe draufsteht cobblestone ziel
krass ist teilweise echte leute
verstecken sich dann einfach machen
wahrscheinlich die augen von toyota zu
und denkt man sieht sie nicht
[Musik]
bekomme ich will ich habe bock intica zu
ein bisschen abzuwarten ich will jetzt
ein bisschen zusammenrücken mussten
crafter wo da ist er da wie ist es denn
ich habe jetzt so dass jetzt überall
besteht im blog darüber erwarte ich bin
ein papa papa hat man richtig richtig
schnell ist
gefunden wurden aber egal schlechtes
versteckt dann finde ich dich jetzt ich
finde ich auf jeden fall
ich weiß dass du bist du bist ein
holzblock auf jeden fall informationen
zu viel ich will nicht warten ich bin
viel zu passiv
[Musik]
bei mir hat
aber welcher bahn diamant schwerte ich
habe irgendwie das waren hat man die hat
man ja dann ist er voll schwer als
heiland sie gestört wenn man heute
vertreten alle drauf gehen ich dann geht
das klar
händler darauf gehen aber meistens so
faces hier eine lobby ja so richtige
fach faces halt mal hier kann man sie
richtig heißt manchmal voll witz ja
manche leute sind favorit aus oderwitz
wenn ich mir überlege dass im echten
leben auch so aussehen ist auf jeden
fall hat was einen tipp angezogen wie
sein youtube youtube world blabla wie
das heißt dass dieses spiel ein echtes
feuer in dem also drehen muss ja hab ich
nie hinbekommen so krass weil sie achte
meinte diese diese zauberwürfel genau
die man nicht halten kann ja auf der map
aber okay du bist okay okay ich glaube
und man ist das miese alter wenn die
anderen einfach unfähig sind findet kann
[Musik]
ich denke hey was geht eher darum ich
bin hoch gelaufen auf einmal kommt ihm
herunter weil er so komisch
blogs war glaube ich dir als auch noch
welche seien immer im wasser gucken was
ist auf jeden fall immer wieder kinder
die ins wasser gefallen
druck da ist zum beispiel am burgsee
wegschwimmt so behindert aus wenn diese
blöcke dasein rumgehen sind wenn diesem
hoch und runter hilfen sind simon buss
oberland und hörte den amboss neuen nein
nein
läuft der amboss vorweg ja und der
andere hatten es getötet ja geil geil
ich feiere dich hab ich habe gateway
points for killing bastian ist ein
richtiger hier kommen auch richtig
berechnen sondern es gibt im wasser gibt
so kleine kanal sollen irgendwie hätte
hier ein so heftig das mache ich
demnächst irgendwann als was denn keiner
nicht okay finde ich dieses geräusch so
ätzend
ich möchte das auch noch mal ran sagt
immer mehr auch wenn ich das mache
schade im vierten block vom alter
mittlerweile kommt echt immer
alternativen getötet nicht würdig sind
nein also dann bekommst du den hab ich
aber hier fehlt einfach mal so ein blog
da kann man sich gut verstecken als
amboss zum beispiel leute verstehen das
spiel irgendwie weiß gar nicht ob ich
das gefühl ich bin zum ersten mal in dem
ich meine nein bei der läufer die leute
immer bei mir läuft richtig auf jeden
fall richtig
pro gamer das ist ein richtiger profi da
machst du normal ich will ich will die
runterspringen irgendwie starke leistung
was eigentlich man sich hier oben
versteckt fließen
ich weiß nicht
zeitig essen hat das essen etwa vier
tage nach dem okay das war's es wieder
mal vorbei das natürlich können weil
zeit vorbei erst einmal ganzen runde
machen noch einen dran dann van bo
74 ich bin ich fit bin ich gern ein blog
ein holzblock weiß nicht wo ich schon
länger zu hause square blöd da manchmal
ein anderes suchen
ich dachte es gibt nur die maps gibt es
nochmal die nehmen weil dann hab ich
keller versteckt wenn ich der block bin
richtig denke er hoffentlich was im zaun
oder so was ich dann irgendwie mitte
fertig werden kann man ein großes werden
erst brachte so ganz unauffällig tätigen
versteckt okay wenn ich dann immer aufs
dach fliegen klenk x factor zaun jetzt
wirklich geworden
ich gehe es hier einfach mal hier oben
drauf ich gehe zurück auf diesen scheiß
auf diese scheiß brunnen obendrauf
markus und es irgendwie geht
nein es hat funktioniert das vorderrad
das wasserdichte hier oben einfach soll
traurig werde es findet einfach mal in
einen schuppen versteckt
okay okay ich glaube das ist gut das ist
zwar im wasser aber ich glaub ich finde
mich keiner aber bist du unten die sind
in dieser woche drin in diesem loch ja
das ist mega dass der gucken die
wenigsten rein
ich höre ich kam von meinem versteck aus
die ganze map überblicken
er sieht mich einfach mal gar nicht sehr
dämlich es hier ich habe erst gedacht
ich komm' crafter warum startest du die
surfer machst du so was ein solcher
sorry es tut mir echt leid weil oder
nein nicht ich bin schuld du bist ein
zaun der wegrennt stört im wasser kommt
zu mir ich verrate ich dann okay
sitting on it blog blog kooptech projekt
gewesen welt wäre dieses eine loch da
gegangen wo außenrum diese ganzen
anderen lok blogs bist du bist so ein
log blockerin holzblock soll unseren
plan wo meine mama hat jetzt essen
fertig ich schreibe ich komme in drei
minuten
es geht ab luca
alter verpiss dich nicht heraus nein es
kommt nicht mehr raus seid ihr damit
eben auch erst so richtig abgefragt
alter das ist echt cool ein anderer blog
wir gucken sich gegenseitig an okay ganz
romantisch hallo ich glaube ich habe
mich verliebt
ach ich liebe dich holzblock deine
kurven sie sind so eckig ich würde gerne
mehr
ich würde gerne mit dir erotische
spielchen treiben
ich kam ein stückchen näher zu dir hallo
alter noch so ein anderer ich glaub ich
will auch noch mitmachen so innig laufen
holz dreier schieben was da los ist und
bei opel dagegen wie bist du denn katja
ott der bug damit herum dass wenn wir
das knochenbruchrisiko über uns genau
der sieg hat jetzt genau über ihr alter
als komm runter löscher habe ich gesehen
wie schnell verstecken
da habe ich in mich rein griechen vega
kein sieger gerade erst jetzt als erster
über den rücken gelaufen ich nicht
gesehen
es gibt doch einfach massiv geld ist
komplett hier in front ja wirklich die
laufen durch die merk- und hauen einfach
hier im blog aber die blöcke die
auffällig irgendwo stehen
die gucken so einfach nur an und
abonnieren oder so was ich weiß ich was
die machen leute
es gibt auf jeden fall bei denen neue
ziemlich viele affen die so was spielen
ich will ihnen die weglaufen stratmann
her kommen lassen anlass ein bisschen
randale schieben jetzt kreislauf weg
lass mal du erst mal hinten drin ist ja
schon nach vorn du bleibst und ich weiß
dass auch ein plan möchte jetzt nochmals
ärger stress im rudel mache das weil ich
tot bin da kommen töte dich nein das
dialog
ich habe einfach mal geboxt alter das
protour und er hat mich einfach mal
nicht siehst du dich in der schwimm-
oder töte mich kommen wissen stellt udo
kalms so auffällig ich finde ich gut
verschwinde jedermänner lücke da jetzt
einfach so behindert auf er schwingt
sogar getötet hektar zum anderen dann
stimmt dieser typen zauner daher jetzt
jetzt lasst mich aber am leben alltag
mal ich mach ein bisschen vorstands vor
dem bisschen bekommst
[Musik]
realistisch da können schon andere
direkt ein c1 c1e ok power after a block
erfolg gibt es einen scheißdreck in
minecraft was wir krass so 89 kommt
lasst mich jetzt einmal ein spiel
gewinnen also das recht mal aber ich
komme mir vorbei und guckt mich ganz
okay vielleicht kann ich dir ein diamant
geben sodass er kratzt dann will ich
nicht beleidigen schreibt gries checker
tut mir leid wenn er dich ja aber ob ich
nein welcher ich bin hacker
zugeschrieben also voll beleidigend es
hat mich auch ein bisschen getroffen
ich lade alle sagen du bist einsamen
darf sich einsamen innenraums verpiss
dich es klappt das geht ab lukas knab
was geht
hey lass es gewohnt das versteck jetzt
immer gut freut euch gefallen hat dürfte
ich einen daumen hoch geben wenn ihr
wollt könnt jetzt auch einfach in die
kommentare schreiben
er will nur puls in den kommentaren in
den kommentaren
ich bin in den kommentaren der ja in den
momentan ist er okay es in der
beschreibung in aktion und beim nächsten
treffen